Hey everyone, it's Mike from Orderflow
here. I'm excited to show you the
Orderflow Reader AI in action. You know,
what I'm going to do is a side-by-side
comparison between ChatGPT, which is the
most common
AI tool out there, and compare it to the
output from Orderflow Reader AI. So, you
know, all you got to do is you you find
a chart you want to analyze. Now, you
know, this is bonds, right? We're in a
nice trending up, but I'll show you the
power of Orderflow Reader AI. You know,
we just sort of go back uh you will
choose a time where the market is just
basically, you know, it looks like it's
going sideways. You know, here we are
like mostly going sideways 1
12 22 basically to 1 12 13. This is in
the bonds, you know, again, this is an
area where where traders, um you know,
want to use the power of Orderflow to
sort of determine which way the market
is going to go potentially. So, all you
have to do is you just uh screenshot it
the chart itself. So, you know, people
ask, you know, what's the best tool for
screenshotting? Uh I use the one that
comes with uh the computer, you know,
Windows. It's just called um
what is it called? Snipping Tool, all
right? It's right there. Now, you know,
I have it pinned to my toolbar, but
if you don't have it, just type in
Snipping Tool and you'll see it uh it'll
come up for you. So, all you got to do
is just click uh new screenshot here.
Do do do, just click you know, what you
want to save, then save it to wherever.
I'll just save it to my uh desktop.
We'll call this chart uh
I don't know,
28s here, okay?
Then, you know, you just close it. So,
what I'll do is I will drop it into
Orderflow Reader. So, chart 28 is right
here. Click analyze. Okay? That's it.
That's all you got to do. Now, if you
wanted to use ChatGPT, what you'd have
to do then is uh you'll upload the same
chart. Okay, chart 28.
And then you have to prompt it, right?
You have to tell what to look for, okay?
So, again, you know, unless you're
good at using AI and know how to prompt,
um you know, it might be a little bit of
a struggle for you. So, you know, let's
say perform
Well, now let's say uh
Look at at this. Well, we'll start here,
okay? Act as an Orderflow Trader
and analyze this chart. Um
Tell me about the important Orderflow.
And based
off of the existing Orderflow,
what should the market do? What should
the market do next? Okay?
I mean, you know, you're going to have
to write it out. You guys you got to be
very specific on what you're going to
ask, you know, and and in the time that
I wrote this, um
the Orderflow Reader already spit out uh
a lot of information for me. So,
go here. And you know, the thing with uh
you know, ChatGPT and and Claude and
these other tools, you know, you got to
prompt it. So, you have to tell it what
to look for, okay? So,
here, okay? On Orderflow Reader while
ChatGPT is working, you can see it's
already uh saying, you know, the current
bar it starts always at the current bar.
It says it's bullish, okay? So, this
market is is bullish right here. And it
tells you about the important Orderflow.
Now, it's giving you the bar-to-bar
comparisons on previous bars and it says
there's a reversal. So, you know,
remember on the chart here, um let me
get the chart back up. You know, we're
looking at this chart and Orderflow
Reader is telling me based off of, you
know, the last two bars, it's a
potential reversal taking place here,
okay?
Um then it talks about the key bullish
and bearish zones based off of the
Orderflow and what happened. Uh current
bar position. It's saying current bar
closed at uh 1 12 19.
All right? And it's talking about that.
Market context is saying the succession
narrative is one of a battle, you know,
it's it's neutral, okay? Final verdict
is bullish, you know, but kind of weak
bullish and it says, you know, while the
market is in rotational balance,
evidence favors a bullish attempt as the
current bar pushes towards resistance at
1 12 19.
Okay?
Um you know, it's supported by two
recent instances of powerful seller
absorption around the 1 12 13 1 12 14
area. Now, this is where
I think
Orderflow Reader will help a lot of
traders is it gives you lessons directly
based off of this chart here. Okay? So,
you know, you upload a chart that you
think looks interesting in the Orderflow
and it's going to
Orderflow A Reader AI tells you um the
key Orderflow lessons that you can learn
specifically from this chart. Talks
about the large volume absorption,
trapped traders, delta reversal,
cumulative delta divergence.
Okay? And again, you know, the final
verdict was bullish, you know, kind of
on the weak, you know, it's got here it
says all three align current bar, bar
comparison, reversal. The context is
slightly bullish. That's where it's
leaning towards, okay?
Let's see what uh ChatGPT spit out here,
okay? Let's take a Let's uh look at this
like an Orderflow Trader, not just a
chart viewer.
Um do do do, sellers were aggressive,
you know, early back here, okay, fine.
Mid move, initial buying continuation,
high test, short delta divergence,
microstructure, momentum is fading, what
this tells us. Um
Orderflow narrative sequence, sellers
failed rally, bullish bias, buyers take
control. Okay, [snorts] it's just kind
of general stuff there. Transition from
initial buying distribution, potential
reversal. What should happen next? Is a
rotation lower. Rotation lower
or a pullback. Buyers are exhausted at
its high. It's It's saying buyers are
exhausted up here. That's interesting. I
don't really see any signs of
exhaustion.
Um
Invalidation when you're wrong if the
market reclaims 1 12 21 or 22 and shows
strong strong strong stacked bid
imbalances, delta expansion, price
follow-through, then sellers failed.
Okay. Well, yeah, obviously if you trade
higher, it's going to be bullish, but
you know, I want to know based off of
what is coming on here
in the Orderflow, you know, is this
market bullish or bearish? So, it gives
you a short idea cuz that's the higher
probability setup. Look for failed
pushes into high absorption or delta
positive. Okay, yeah, I mean, that's
what you would look for if
if it's going to
sell off, right? Cuz the trade idea is
is um a short. Long idea if we break out
above the highs. Well, no kidding. If we
break out above the highs, yeah, you'd
want to be long. I mean, that's pretty
obvious. Bottom line,
chart is showing buyers losing control
at high. Smart money is likely
distributing to aggressive buyers.
Market is more likely to rotate down
before continuing up.
Okay, so it's saying market is going
down, right? Last one. Market is more
likely to rotate down, right? Short idea
is the higher probability setup. You
know, this is interesting because on
Orderflow Reader AI, the exact same
chart that I uploaded, it's saying final
verdict is bullish, but it's it's kind
of a weaker bullish signal, right? It's
not a super strong one, but it's looking
for the market to go up. Um
what will the market do? Let's pull up
the chart again. Okay, next bar.
Uh next bar went up.
Up. Up. Okay.
So,
we rallied, you know, it was ChatGPT
right or wrong? Well, it gave you a
short and a long idea.
Invalidation is if the market reclaims 1
12 21 22. Yeah, we did eventually, but
you know,
you don't want to be waiting, right? I
mean, it's giving you a bunch of
different ideas, a long idea, a short
idea. You can see here, this is the
verdict right here from Orderflow
Reader.
It's just saying it's bullish.
Okay? But not only that. So, here is
just, you know, it talks about some of
the Orderflow.
But here, right? To me, this is the most
powerful thing. It gives you, based off
of the Orderflow chart you upload,
talks about the large volume absorption,
why it matters. Trapped traders, why it
matters. Delta reversal pattern, what it
is, why it matters. Cumulative delta
divergence, why it matters, right? So,
that you can learn from your charts,
okay? And it doesn't just give you like,
oh, signs of absorption and divergence.
Okay? Here tells you what it saw
in the Orderflow.
So,
you know, it's teaching you, right? It's
not just an analysis tool, it's a
teaching tool. It's going to help you
see things that maybe you've overlooked
in your trading, in your analysis.
So,
again, you know, which is better?
Obviously, you know,
I believe Orderflow Reader's is 10 times
better because, you know, here ChatGPT
just and these other tools, they just
give you like a general broad
brushstroke of Orderflow terms, you
know, it's not really giving you
anything solid um
that you can use to learn from. Whereas
here, you know, it's nice and then if
you want, you could even export it into
a PDF
that you can save, right? And then, you
know, what I like to do now is what I'm
doing is I save all my PDFs.
All right? I mean, you know, you got you
need a lot of paper, obviously, when
this is just a simple two-page printout
with the chart as well. So, you could
form your own playbook
based off of your market, your chart,
what you thought was interesting in the
Orderflow, or maybe it was something you
couldn't quite figure out in the
Orderflow that you're struggling to to
to understand it. Now, you can use this
and the beauty is
Order Flow Reader, I've trained it and
I'm constantly training it and I'm
constantly adding new things every week.
I keep adding new nuances in the order
flow. ChatGPT is way, way behind. So
again, you know, if I know this tool can
help a lot of traders. If you're
interested right now, you can still get
in. I have the ground floor pricing.
It's just a one-time payment as opposed
to when this actually goes mainstream.
And I'm talking with a few companies
about it. They want to bring it to
market and it's going to be, you know,
they're talking $59 a month. But, you
know, right now you can just get it at a
one-time uh price. So, just click the
link below, guys, and I'll see you on
the inside.